[Musique]
au palais de justice de vesoul
un jeune père de famille va comparaître
il lui est reproché des violences
conjugales
un dossier sur trois en haute saône
après sa garde à vue il a été déféré
devant le procureur avant de se
retrouver à la barre du tribunal
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils avaient
appelé la police non d'accord qui les
voisins est pourquoi les voisins elle la
police malade parce que ça crie très
fort d'accord peut-être parce qu'ils
sont inquiets quand il ya des grosses
disputes parce qu'on vous chiffonne est
ce qu on vous tire les cheveux et pour
les autres x men
le 14 septembre le 20 décembre il se
passe rien mais les voisins appellent la
police
vous n'êtes pas victime je vous vous
êtes une victime
peut-être que vous l'acceptez pas je
suis pas posé de question pour vous mais
pas de mettre en difficulté mais vous
êtes une victime d'une relation de
couple anormal il semble que par le
passé mais également fait l'objet de
petites violences de paf je le condamne
à une peine de 12 mois d'emprisonnement
et surtout bien sûr des livres est
remonté pour celles à fait drôlement
rigolé lorsque l'on voit et cris et
pleurs et la mise à jour
ben moi quand je pleure j'ai aussi le
visage rouge et ce n'est pas pour autant
que j'ai pris un coup mais n'avons
absolument aucun élément puisque madame
ici présente bien vous dit non mais moi
j pas reçu de claques
j'ai pas reçu de violence nous nous
sommes disputés viola dans cette affaire
le procureur a requis de la prison ferme
ils plaident dans l'intérêt de la
société de son bon fonctionnement
c'est la principale mission du ministère
public qu'il représente mais c'est bien
le tribunal qui aura le dernier mot
vous êtes donc monsieur déclaré coupable
de ces trois chefs de poursuite de ces
trois délits en répression monsieur
contenu de votre personnalité de votre
casier judiciaire des faits qui sont
graves
vous êtes condamné monsieur à la peine
de 10 mois d'emprisonnement
vous partez immédiatement en prison à la
maison d'arrêt de dijon le criminal des
fermes à mandat de dépôt à votre
encontre
c'est un miroir de notre société que
nous découvrons dans les murs de ce
tribunal en 2018 ce sont plus de 13
mille six cents procédures qui ont été
transmises des traités par le parquet de
la haute saône un tiers ont donné lieu à
des poursuites a rendez vous avec la
justice
empreint de colère de désespoir et
souvent de souffrance le métier de
procureurs phare de maistre du parquet
était médecin et sont assez proches
vous êtes un médecin de l'âme
malheureusement ce que vous avez ce que
vous voyez ce que vous entendez ici
c'est tous les drames de nos sociétés on
a rarement des bonnes nouvelles
lorsqu'on juge ces personnes lorsqu'on
les défaire on rentre effectivement dans
l'humain on entre dans l'intimité de vie
que personne ne connaît hormis nous et
c'est pour ça que ce métier attire
énormément ces métiers qui sont très
riches en ce sens la journée se poursuit
à l'extérieur cette fois direction gré à
une heure de route de vesoul un
distributeur de billets a été attaqué à
l'explosif en plein centre ville
il faut comprendre et surtout nous
rassurer
c'est aussi une marque par rapport à la
population parce que c'est quand même un
événement tout peut choquer en plein
coeur de ville de faire sauter des
distributeurs explosif on est sur une
équipe criminels quand même assez
préoccupante
[Musique]